HOW CAN THE GOVERNMENT
WASTE ALL THIS MONEY BUT DEMAND
THAT POOR PEOPLE ACCOUNT FOR
THEIR EVERY PURCHASE?
IT DOESN'T EVEN--
>> I CAN EXPLAIN!
LARRY, I'M GONNA EXPLAIN.
( LAUGHTER ).
>> Larry: I'M SORRY, WHO ARE
YOU?
IT'S ME, QUEEN OF THE
WELFAIRIES.
A WELFARE QUEEN, IF YOU WILL.
>> Larry: A WELFARE-- A
WELFAIRY QUEEN, REALLY?
>> UH-HUH.
LOOK AT THE GIRL. I'M BLINGED
OUT!
PLATINUM THIS, DIAMOND THAT,
TAKIN A CRUISE EVERY DAY!
( LAUGHTER )
DAY CRUISE, BOOZE CRUISE.
>> Larry: WHERE DID YOU COME
FROM?
>> FROM THE MIND OF LAWMAKERS.
THEY THINK EVERYBODY ON WELFARE
LOOKS AND TALKS LIKE THIS.
>> Larry: WAIT, SO YOU DON'T
REALLY SOUND LIKE THIS?
>> WELL, IF I WERE TO KEEP IT
100--  THIS IS MY REAL VOICE.
( LAUGHTER )
SO, WELFAIRY, HOW DO YOU
FEEL ABOUT-- THAT'S HER NAME.
( LAUGHTER )
HOW DO YOU FEEL ABOUT THESE
RESTRICTIONS?
>> THEY'RE A LOAD OF RAINBOW
CRAP.
IT'S GOTTEN SO BAD, IN KANSAS
THEY DRUG TEST YOU BEFORE YOU
CAN GET YOUR BENEFITS.
>> Larry: DRUG TESTS?
THAT DOES SEEM LIKE A NUISANCE.
IN ALL FAIRNESS THEY'RE PROBABLY
MAKING SURE DRUG ADDICTS DON'T
GET FREE MONEY.
>> EXCEPT IS COSTS $40 GRAND TO
GET THE TEST, AND ONLY 11 PEOPLE
TESTED POSITIVE OUT OF 2700.
DO YOU KNOW HOW MANY TATTOOS I
COULD HAVE GOTTEN ON THIS WITH
ALL THAT MONEY?
>> Larry: I DIDN'T REALIZE WE
SHARED SO MANY COMMON INTERESTS.
SO YOU DISPELLED THE MYTH
ABOUT WASTING MONEY ON
PEOPLE ON DRUGS. BUT WHAT ABOUT
ALL THE PEOPLE ON WELFARE WHO
ARE GAMING THE SYSTEM? IS THAT
FAIR?
>> LARRY, WITH $25 A DAY, THE
ONLY GAME WE'RE PLAYING IS HOW
TO MAKE THIS MUCH FOOD FEED THIS
MUCH PEOPLE.
( APPLAUSE ).
>> Larry: BUT, YEAH... TRUE,
TRUE.
BUT BUT, IN ALL FAIRNESS, YOU'RE
A FAIRY, RIGHT?
>> I'M A WELFAIRY.
( LAUGHTER )
I'M NOT JESUS!
BUT EVEN IF I WERE, WE'RE NOT
ALLOWED TO BUY FISH.
SO THERE'S REALLY NOT MUCH TO
MULTIPLY.
>> Larry: I GOT IT.
THAT WOULDN'T QUITE WORK.
SO WHAT'S THE TRICK HERE THEN.
>> WELL, LARRY, ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT'S NOT ON THE BANNED
LIST ARE GUNS.
>> Larry: WAIT!
HOLD ON A SECOND!
THAT CANNOT BE TRUE.
WAIT, GUNS?
YOU'RE NOT ALLOWED TO BUY
SEAFOOD, BUT YOU CAN BUY GUNS?
>> YES!
AND WITH GUNS, YOU CAN
TECHNICALLY GET ALL THE SEAFOOD
YOU WANT.
>> Larry: WELFAIRY, NO, HOLD ON,
HOLD ON.
WELFAIRY, NO, NO, NO, GUYS,
WELFAIRY YOU'RE NOT SUGGESTING
THAT TO OUR AUDIENCE.
>> GOTTA GO, GOTTA GO.
>> Larry: WAIT, WELFAIRY.
>> OUT OF HERE.
>> Larry: WHY IS WELFAIRY NOT
GOING?
>> Larry: WAITE, DON'T LEAVE,
WELFAIRY.
DON'T!
NO, WELFAIRY.